now the latest coronavirus figures for
the uk
have been released they show 1 725
people have died
in the last 24 hours and those are
deaths within 28 days
of a positive coronavirus test in terms
of the number of cases that is 25
308 today up from a figure of 20
089 yesterday let's bring in our health
correspondent
ashish and yet another truly shocking
figure
in terms of the number of deaths arshish
yes it's very high we had 1631 people
reported to have lost their lives
yesterday which took us past that grim
total of a hundred
thousand uh uk death toll again today
we are seeing another high figure 1725
more people
dying of with covid within 28 days of a
positive test we were warned that this
was
going to happen we were warned by the
cmo chris whittie last week
during a press briefing at downing
street he said
we are likely to see numbers high
numbers
for at least the next few days and weeks
and those warnings have been sounded by
the chief executive simon stevens of the
national health service and repeated by
patrick valance as well
the reason for this is because it's
we've had this long
peak up to where we are now
through the the autumn and into the
winter
when we get to that peak we think we
might have possibly
passed that peak in some parts of the
country it's not just
a sheer drop the other side we are going
to start
climbing down very slowly at the moment
we're not seeing that climb down we've
got a higher figure
posted today than we did yesterday but
certainly in terms of the people who are
testing positive
indications that that might be slowing
we've seen the admissions rise once we
have admissions
in hospitals invariably sadly there will
be deaths so these figures
as terrible as they are they were
expected
we can only hope that the the lockdown
now is having an effect
and we and that will negate some of the
the mingling
and the infections we saw over christmas
sarah